so joe biden gave the most threatening
presidential speech in american history
last week he spoke in front of a
blood-red backdrop flanked by u.s
marines and he delivered if you take a
step back the blueprint for the rest of
his administration
criminalize dissent
effectively ban the opposition and use
the federal agencies to transform
america into a one-party state
it's called authoritarianism
here's what biden said in a speech the
white house advertised as non-political
watch this
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our republic the
republican party today is dominated
driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
and that is a threat to this country
maggie republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election they promote authoritarian
leaders and they fan the flames of
political violence
that are a threat
to our personal rights
to the pursuit of justice
to the rule of law
to the very soul of this country
it's enough to make your head spin
donald trump has been banned from
speaking in public he has been censored
at the behest of the democratic party he
can no longer go on social media
our electronic town square he's been
totally erased
and yet joe biden says trump and his
supporters promote authoritarian leaders
and he says this at exactly the moment
that he is sending billions of dollars
to ukraine and its authoritarian leaders
every month
authoritarian oh that just scratches the
surface over the past year and a half
the government of ukraine has jailed its
top political rival it has banned
opposition parties and it has outlawed
independent media
oh but that's not authoritarian what's
authoritarian is disagreeing with joe
biden
do that and joe biden will stand in
front of the military he controls and
declare that you were an enemy of the
state
so watching the fanatical support of the
white house
for the actual authoritarians who run
ukraine you can sort of see the template
here
but of course as is always true when joe
biden speaks you can't hold him entirely
responsible because not only did he not
write the words he's not aware that he
spoke them
just the other day he said after giving
the speech when we're quoting i don't
consider any trump supporter a threat to
the country that was on friday
our media seemed to ignore that to be
very disappointed if they heard it
because they listened exactly
to the words biden spoke and they love
them watch
president biden gave a really strong
speech and and i
loved it i
i believe everything he said
it was an urgent wartime address
and something else that really stuck out
to me is that he almost seemed to sort
of be reclaiming patriotism
if you look up fascism in the dictionary
you're going to find all of those things
so i'm really not sure what the
republicans are all and upset about
other than the fact that it was named
obviously republicans i think are the
biggest threats in democracy we don't
separate right-wing extremists and
republican party anymore hillary clinton
told the truth when he said she said
that there were deplorable people in the
republican party supporting donald trump
and they were he was exciting a lot of
racism and misogyny and bigotry the
republicans who were like oh he's
calling us fascists if you're not a
fascist he's not talking about you so
lighten up
oh so if you're innocent you have
nothing to hide don't worry
it's amazing how soviet the whole thing
is joe biden calls for political purges
and law enforcement crackdowns on his
political opponents and state media
cheer him on
in his speech about the threats to our
republic joe biden doesn't mention
anything but domestic threats he doesn't
mention china a single time he mentioned
the border or fentanyl or crime
he only mentioned people who oppose him
politically
and once again
like the obedient little servants they
are
our media cheer him on you have to
wonder about their views on
authoritarianism obviously they're for
it in fact one of these journalists
wrote the speech that would be john
meacham who wrote for many years at news
weeklies and now is america's most banal
historian apparently he had a hand in
writing the speech last week he also
redecorated the oval office at joe
biden's request he is now our
propagandist in chief
and it's not hard to see what inspired
meacham to write that speech on thursday
meacham admires autocrats who silence
their political opponents earlier this
year mitchum went on television to
compare the president of ukraine
zielenski to winston churchill and the
men who stormed the beaches of normandy
we want to prepare you now for a torrent
of cliches because those are the only
chunks of language john meacham is
capable of using
now that you're prepared here it is
quote it may sound sentimental
but it has the virtue of being true
right so at the same time zielenski this
winston churchill figure was
criminalizing dissent in his country he
shut down three television stations as
his spokesman put it those media have
become one of the tools of war against
ukraine so they are blocked in order to
protect national security oh so those tv
stations are sort of like donald trump
or fox news we need to silence them in
order to preserve our democracy
democracy it was only one side gets to
speak
so it really is democracy circa 1972
bulgaria it's a democratic republic
meaning the people who live there have
no representation whatsoever the party
decides it's hard to believe any of this
is happening but it is
and on thursday joe biden and
speechwriter made it explicit
so where's the pushback to this no
president's ever given a speech like
this so you wonder where those pious
defenders of our norms
joe biden announces that we need a
one-party state and he says it flanked
by active duty u.s marines and nobody
says a word
where was mark milley
isn't he a great defender of democracy
where were the cheneys and everyone else
who's upholding
our sacred system of government
where are they
nodding along too embarrassed to speak
now is the time to speak they're always
welcome to speak on this show always
they're always invited here
in the meantime we turn to jackson
hinkle he's the host of the dive with
jackson hinckle on youtube he joins us
now jackson thanks so much for coming on
so there's something really look i
understand people are partisan on tv
there's a lot of pressure to take your
side side
but for biden to get up there and say
the single biggest threat to our country
is anyone who opposes me in the coming
midterm elections and the media to not
along makes you think we've crossed some
kind of line
we have crossed the line tucker and it's
so interesting that uh you know
anyone in the media today would be
saying that they liked what joe biden
said in that speech because it was a
dictator inspired speech
not only that but it seems like a lot of
the practices and the actions that the
bind administration is employing in the
united states right now that were
reflected in that speech
are very closely aligned with what the
dictator zielinski is doing in ukraine
joe biden is plunging us into a fascist
state and he is taking cues from what
zelinski is doing in ukraine to
manufacture this dystopian state and
this dystopian reality in america and
there's no real surprise for me there
because at the end of the day vladimir
zelinski the president of ukraine and
joe biden are controlled by the same
exact people they're controlled by
individuals like george soros and
controlled by people like klaus schwab
at the world economic forum and they're
going to do whatever they want uh you
know to put it quite simply zielinski's
using the intelligence community in
ukraine and the nazis of thugs in
ukraine to silence freedom-loving
ukrainians joe biden in the united
states though he can't remember what he
had for breakfast this morning or who
his wife is his handlers and his cronies
are prepping the cia the fbi antifa the
irs and now ministry of truth to attack
freedom-loving americans
maybe someone should have on the in the
opposition party the one he's calling
effectively illegal should have paused
before funding
this insanity in ukraine which is
tanking our economy and making a mockery
of democracy
before signing off on it and just
putting
ukrainian flag lapel pins on and nodding
dutifully to joe biden
why didn't anyone do that
you'd think that they do that but so
many of these individuals in washington
dc the neoconservatives the rhinos and
the entire democratic party are beholden
to the military industrial complex and
that is extremely out of line with what
average americans need right now we
don't have clean drinking water in
jackson mississippi yet we're sending
seven billion dollars over to ukraine a
country that i'm sure most of these
congress people couldn't even point to
on a map it's insane the white house
this week tucker i'm sure you saw came
out and said that anyone who doesn't
hold an opinion reflected by the
majority of the american public is
extreme and therefore an extreme miss
well what does that make joe biden only
38
of americans if you believe the polls
and what they tell us if you believe
they're that high only 38 of americans
agree with joe biden so by the white
house's own definition that makes him an
extremist
yeah and so much for minority rights
also i mean i thought you were allowed
to disagree uh this really is quite
quite a moment we're living through jack
single thanks so much
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight